I guess one question I think I always
have to talk to people about is like
when thus freemium sort of makes sense
or like what is the advantage of going
with Freeman how is it different from
like other typical models and then why
is it good for like a subscription
software company the reason you approach
freemium is because the idea is like one
you approach your free users as if
they're lead generation and that they're
part of your marketing side of the
equation like these people the ones who
didn't give the word out for on there
and the most important thing is that you
should be aware of it's like is the
market large enough that a small
conversion of those people using the
product is enough to make the company
large so for example a bakery a local
Baker you can only serve people within a
small area their potential market size
is a lot smaller so you can't just give
the tunnel way for free cuz like that
conversion rate won't make that business
sustained but when you have an internet
software company the marginal cost of
replication of offering services is very
very cheap and the potential size of the
market is huge because it's the whole
world everyone on the internet and
reforms those big enough like all the
use cases for it if you have a software
that is very niche and that the cost of
each new user or a free user is
extremely high you want to rethink maybe
the mechanics of using Freeman like it
it's not a one-size-fits-all for every
company